عامر لافي في اسطنبول
كمالك كما بدات في هذه النافذه تقدم على
الرئيس الحالي اردوغان في اسطنبول هل
اتضحت استراتيجيه الرئيس اردوغان لكسب
مزيد من الاصوات في هذه الجوله الثانيه من
الانتخابات
نعم جلال يعني منذ اليوم الاول لاعلان
نتائج الجوله الاولى وبدا اردوغان
بالتركيز على اسطنبول وعلى العديد طبعا من
المدن التركيه لكن اسطنبول تبقى كما ذكرت
في اهم المدن واكبر المدن الانتخابيه
ومكانه في نفوس الاتراك هذا الحي الذي انا
فيه هو حي ايوب سلطان ربما هذه احد مشاهد
الاهتمام
بهاء باسطنبول وتحديدا بالعديد من الاحياء
التي فقد فيها حزب العداله والتنميه
والرئيس اردوغان اصواتا هذا الحي
جلال كان محسوبا دائما على العداله
والتنميه في انتخابات 2018 حصل اردوغان
على 50% في هذا الحي لكن في هذه
الانتخابات في الرابع عشر من مايو الماضي
حصل على 46% وبالتالي يحاول رفع اصواته في
هذه المنطقه يوزعون الكثير من البطاقات
والمنشورات التي تعرف الناس هنا بانجازات
حزب العداله والتنميه وما قام به لهذه
التي كما تعلم هي التي اوصلته الى الرئاسه
عندما كان رئيسا لبلديتها وبالتالي ايضا
تركيز على موضوع تحالف المعارضه ايضا مع
ما يوصف هنا بالرديف السياسي لحزب العمال
كردستاني هناك الزميل المصور ينقلنا الى
خيمه اخرى مجاوره يا خيمه حزب الشعب
الجمهوري
مرشح المعارضه كماله يحاولون الاخرين ايضا
تسويق مرشحهم في مكان مقابل لمكان الذي
يتجمع فيه حزب العداله والتنميه هذا
المشهد متكرر جمال في اكثر من منطقه في
اسطنبول وفي هذا الحي تحديدا هناك ايضا
التركيز على الانجازات الاقتصاديه التي
يمكن ان يقدمها
كمولو للمواطنين الاتراك والتركيز ايضا
بشكل كبير على قضيه اللاجئين تعلم اسطنبول
احدى اكثر المدن التي تحتوي على لاجئين
يتحدث حسب الشعب الجمهوري على انها تحتوي
على اكثر من مليون لاجئ يعيدون المواطنين
الاتراك بانهم خلال اقل من سنه سيرسلونهم
الى بلدانهم وبالتالي واضح التركيز وواضح
ايضا هنا يعني اقول الانتقال الكبير لانه
قبل الجوله الاولى كان حزب الشعوب حزب
الشعب الجمهوري يتحدث عن عدد تقريبا ثلاث
مليون ونصف ومن خلال السنتين سيقوم
بارسالهم الى سوريا على اعتبار ان معظم
اللاجئين هم اللاجئين السوريين لكن الربعه
سقف عاليا واصبح الحديث عن انهم اكثر من
عشره ملايين وبانهم سيقوم بارسالهم من
بلدانهم بمجرد ان يصل الى الحكم
عامر حماسه الناخب في اسطنبول هل حافظت
على زخمها في هذه الجوله الثانيه تعتقد
يعني هذا جلال اترككم ايضا مع الصور اذا
يعني هذه اكثر النقاط التي يهتم بها
السلسله الاتراك في هذه المرحله لان هناك
تخوف منك الطرفين حزب الاعداء والتنميه
والرئيس اردوغان يتخوف من عتراجع مؤيدين
من الذهاب الى صناديق الاختراع الاعتبار
انه حصل على كما تعلم
49.5 وهو لا يحتاج الكثير وربما قد يتبادر
الى دهن مرشحين وناخبيه هنا باننا فزنا
علي امتحان فلماذا نذهب الى صناديق
الاختراع وبالتالي يحفز بشكل يومي ابو
رشحيه على الذهاب الى صندوق الاقتراع ايضا
نفس الشيء بالنسبه لحزب الشعوب الشعب
الجمهوري الذي طبعا يتحدى يخشى من ان
حصوله على درجه لم تكن متوقع ونسبه لم تكن
متوقعه ربما هذا يصيب مرشعي بالاحباط
ويجعلهم لا يتوجهون الى صناديق الاقتراع
على اعتبار ان الفوز اصبح صعبا بالنسبه
لهم وبالتالي ايضا المعسكر الاخر يدعو
ناخذه الى التوجه بقوه لصناديق الاختراع
وباعتقادي ومن خلال تجربتي ربما اعتقد
انها لن تتراجع كثير روما تتراجع بشكل
ضعيف لكن الشعب التركي بشكل عام يفضل ان
يشارك في الانتخابات النسبه المشاركه هي
الاعلى في العالم في تقدير لن تتراجع عن
85% جلل